nos piden graficar la función f x igual
a raíz cuadrada de 0.5 x menos 1 muy
bien la idea es que vamos a tomar una
muestra de valores de x que estén en el
dominio de la función vamos a evaluar la
función en estos valores y con eso vamos
a obtener algunos puntos de la gráfica
que después vamos a conectar para darnos
una idea de cómo está la gráfica vale
bueno entonces déjame poner por aquí una
tabla y en esta tabla lo que vamos a
hacer lo que vamos a hacer es calcular
la función en algunos valores de x si te
das cuenta estoy poniendo tres columnas
ahorita te digo por que en la primera
columna voy a poner equis y en la última
voy a poner
efe de x vale
la idea va a ser la siguiente aquí
tenemos que sacar raíz cuadrada de 0.5
equis y eso usualmente es complicado
sacar raíces sin una calculadora es muy
difícil si tenemos raíz de 7 va a estar
feo entonces la idea es que vamos a
intentar hacer que a raíz de 0.5 x sea
un número entero es decir vamos a
intentar que 0.5 x sea un número
cuadrado entonces pues déjame poner por
aquí 0.5 x 0.5 equis y la idea es que
vamos a obtener los valores de x los
valores muestran pensando en que
queremos que 0.5 x sea un número
cuadrado un cuadrado perfecto vale
entonces déjame ponerle por aquí que
queremos que sea un cuadrado perfecto
entonces qué números pueden ser
cuadrados perfectos pues el 0 por
ejemplo el 0 es cuadrado perfecto
entonces déjame poner por aquí el 0 el 1
también es cuadrado perfecto el 2 y el 3
no porque ningún número al cuadrado da
ni dos ni tres entonces aquí tendría que
seguir con el 4 va luego vamos a obtener
valores de x en realidad podríamos
probar cualquier valor que quisiéramos
de x pero otra vez la idea es que
queremos que la cuenta no salga facilita
ahorita vas a ver a qué me refiero
déjame seguir con algunos otros cuantos
cuadrados
el siguiente cuadrado es 9 el siguiente
cuadrado es 16 y finalmente voy a poner
el 25 vale bueno ahí tenemos 6 valores
para 0.5 x pero lo que nosotros
necesitamos son valores de x entonces
cómo le hacemos para obtener para
obtener el valor de x conociendo 0.5 x
pues resolvemos una ecuación por ejemplo
la primera nos dice que es 0.5 x
es igual a cero y eso es lo que nos
diste nos dice esta entrada entonces si
0.5 x es igual a 0 x es igual a
dividimos entre 0.5 entre ambos lados
nos queda que x es igual a 0 entre 0.5
que es 0 entonces aquí sería x igual a 0
pero b lo único que hicimos fue dividir
entre 0.5 y eso es lo mismo que
multiplicar por 2 déjame poner en otro
color esto para que sea un poco más
claro
entonces si queremos obtener ahora el
valor de x aquí tenemos que dividir 1
entre 0.5 pero dividir entre 0.5 es lo
mismo que multiplicar por dos así que x
nos queda 2 y de manera similar aquí x
nos quedan 8 acá nos queda 18 de este
lado nos queda 32 y finalmente el último
valor es x igual a 50 kva entonces estos
valores de x nos garantizan obtener
estos valores de 0.5 x y a partir de eso
ya va a ser muy fácil calcular fx vamos
a hacer las cuentas para ver cuánto nos
queda vale entonces pensemos qué
x es igual a 0 y vamos a calcular efe de
x entonces si x es igual a 0 fx es raíz
usando la definición es raíz de 0.50
punto 5 por 0 y luego a eso tenemos que
restarle 10.5 por 00 menos 1 es igual a
menos 1 raíz de 000 menos 1 es menos 1
muy bien ahora vamos con el segundo
valor aquí tenemos que hacer raíz de 0.5
por x x es 2 entonces es 0.5 por 2 y a
eso tenemos que restarle 10 puntos 5 por
2 pues justo lo tenemos aquí verdad es 1
entonces nos queda 0.5 por 2 que es 1
raíz de unos 1 menos uno nos queda igual
a cero muy bien déjame continuar para
que veamos cómo cómo va esta cosa ahora
vamos a tener raíz de 0.5
8 verdad x es igual a 8 pero justo
hicimos las cosas para que esta raíz nos
quedara raíz de 4 entonces raíz de 4 es
2 y tenemos que restar 1 esto nos queda
igual a 2 perdón
2 - 1 es1 nos queda igual a 1 entonces
ya se ve el patrón como que estamos
sumando 1 verdad déjame continuar con
los otros valores ahora tenemos que
hacer raíz de raíz de 0.5 por 18 0.5 por
18 9 raíz de 9 es 3 y 3 - 1 es igual a 2
muy bien ya nada más nos faltan dos
valores aquí es raíz de 0.5 por 32 menos
1 nos queda raíz de 16 menos uno o sea
cuatro menos uno que es tres y
finalmente en color verde
voy a poner raíz de raíz de 0.5 por 50
menos 10 puntos 5 por 50 25 la raíz de
cinco menos 1 es igual a 4
excelente entonces observa esto está
padre pudimos haber tomado una muestra
arbitraria de valores de x pero iba a
quedar muy feo por las raíces cuadradas
pensando en que 0.5 x es un cuadrado
entonces ya todo quedó mucho más limpio
vale bueno ahora sí ya tenemos los
puntos ya tenemos nuestra tabla los
valores de x y los de fx déjame graficar
la función observa todos estos valores
de x son mayores iguales que 0 y no es
casualidad de hecho
de hecho el dominio de la función f x
son los números que son mayores o
iguales que 0 ya que se debe esto porque
el dominio está restringido pues tiene
que ver con esta raíz de acá con raíz de
0.5 x para que un número tenga raíz
cuadrada como lo hemos visto hasta
ahorita es el número tiene que ser mayor
o igual que 0 ahorita no vamos a pensar
en números imaginarios y si no los
conoces ni te preocupes vale el chiste
es que necesitamos que 0.5 x sea mayor o
igual que 0 0.5 x sea mayor
x 0.5
se me estaba escapando esa equis esto
queremos que sea mayor o igual que 0 y
por lo tanto x es mayor o igual que se
vale entonces pues el dominio son las x
mayores o iguales que 0 y esto de aquí
es una muestra ahora sí vamos a graficar
este ya dije mucho y no he dibujado nada
entonces vamos a poner por aquí a claro
es que dije todo eso para justificar que
que los ejes me van a quedar así déjame
ponerse un poco más arriba
entonces como el dominio son las x
mayores o iguales que 0 le voy a dar más
importancia a este lado del eje x acá
voy a poner el eje e igual a efe de x y
vamos a ver qué escala tendríamos que
poner aquí y acá vale haber x va de 0 a
50 entonces sería bueno poner por acá
más o menos 10 por aquí 20 por acá 30
por acá 40 y por acá se encuentra vale
entonces estos son los valores en x que
podemos tomar y ahora vamos a ver qué
pasa con ya lleva de menos 1 a 4 bueno
entonces déjame poner por aquí por aquí
está bien por aquí voy a poner el menos
uno por acá el uno por aquel 2 el 3
y finalmente el 4 muy bien entonces
déjame pasar los valores de esta tabla
aquí a la gráfica entonces tomando este
color como rojo tenemos que uno de los
puntos es el 0,21 que sería el 0 en x
coma menos 1 entonces sería este de
acabará el 0 - 1 ahora hay que poner el
2 0
voy a poner el 2 0 el 2 está bien
cerquita de aquí si está como a la
quinta parte de entre 0 y 10 entonces
está como por acá va entonces este de
acá es el punto 2 coma
pero bueno está un poco chiquito pero es
el 20 ok vamos con el tercer punto en
color morado este de aquí es el 81 el 81
el 8 queda como por acá aquí está el 1
este es el 1 en y entonces este de aquí
es el 8,1 sigamos con este color azul al
color azul le corresponde el 18,2 18,2
más o menos por ahí luego sigue le voy a
poner el 18,2 luego sigue el 32 3
voy a agarrar este color azul que es un
poco más claro que el anterior 32 está
como por acá con matrices como por aquí
vale este es el 32,3 y finalmente
tenemos el punto 50,4 50,4 muy bien
entonces 50,4 que queda como por acá
muy bien entonces los puntos como que
cada vez se alejan más rápidamente del
eje y ok ya tenemos estos puntos son
algunos puntos en la gráfica ahora sí
para trazar la gráfica lo que tenemos
que hacer es conectar estos puntos vale
entonces déjame tomar el color blanco y
más o menos la gráfica nos quedaría algo
así
entonces aquí viene una línea blanca que
pasa por este punto rosa luego pasa por
el morado se empieza a costar un poco
más para pasar por este por el azulito y
luego pasa por este que es color cian
bueno azul claro azul claro más o menos
por ahí y finalmente se hace todavía más
horizontal
hasta que pasa por este chin bueno ahí
me falló tantito el pulso pero tiene que
pasar por ahí vale pasa por todos esos
cinco puntos seis puntos es que este no
le puse coordenadas este es el 50,4
entonces pasa por esos seis puntos y
ahora si esta línea blanca ya tiene
todos los puntos de la gráfica de la
función y si te das cuenta se parece
algo así como una p como a una parábola
acostada y justo es eso justo es una
parábola girada vale bueno entonces ya
tenemos la gráfica de la función y esta
gráfica muestra todos los puntos del
estilo x coma
fx para la función fx igual a raíz de
0.5 x menos 1